hey what's up it's a sweetie make sure
you check me out on the bootleg Kev
podcast
show we got a special guest in here
fresh with her Starbucks order first of
all sweetie's here ladies and gentlemen
what's up sweetie welcome what is your
go-to order at Starbucks a chai latte
with two extra shots
I like that have you ever had Dutch Bros
you know I keep hearing about them it's
like uh it's like a it's like the
Illuminati coffee that [ __ ] is so fire
every time I see they spot it's a line
that's hella long I think that's why I
haven't tried it yet yeah it's
ridiculous and the people are like
really really happy there so almost like
annoying really like you pull up and
they're like they just want to talk and
I love that it's amazing yeah so you got
this uh
We're not gonna call it an EP
we got a nice playlist project it's like
a six piece like a beer pack you know
it's a it's a six pack of of high-end
heart selters and or beers mm-hmm yeah
um the single life
it is uh by the way the artwork is fire
thank you shout out to Olga it reminded
me of like um some like 70s or 80s like
vibey like I would want to have it on
like a
like I'd want to hold that like on vinyl
oh wow does that make sense you know
like some like Stevie Wonder type [ __ ]
super vibing thank you
um why because obviously your album's on
the way
um and your fans are probably getting a
little impatient
so why why now
you know it's been a year and I've
recorded hella songs and
I just wanted to heat back up before I
just put my album out right you know
and the album is pretty [ __ ] music yeah
it's the album and the movement the
album and the movement get it right and
get it tight and it's ices obviously the
movement as well uh-huh yeah
um so on this record uh I listened to
the uh to I mean it's six songs so it's
an easy listen very I mean you were I
thought he was making a statement on
this [ __ ] for real like if I
just felt like I felt like a bad [ __ ]
getting out of my car really I love that
that was my goal you know like one thing
I really wanted to tap into you know
growing up when I would listen to like
Trina Kim foxy Nikki like they made me
feel like an Uber bad [ __ ] it made me
feel expensive they made me feel
motivated so I wanted that same
sensation with this project yeah and I
think too like uh I feel like that kind
of energy is like I mean I mean there's
some great music out there but I feel
like coming from the perspective of like
celebrating being single I feel like
it's you know job accomplished thank you
yeah
um well the last year you've kind of
been like like uh I've heard you've been
like just locked up in the studio just
banging [ __ ] out I have I love the
studio now yeah I love it what is the
studio like must-haves for you a
comfortable blanket okay some candles
um a little bit of wine mmm Wine Time
and um I like to like clean it every
other hour I hate a dirty studio so
you'll be in the studio and you're like
I'll freshen up we gotta we gotta switch
this up new candles no it's just like
you know because people order food oh
yeah you have Bossa Nova in the corner
yeah I don't like none of that like if
the runners ain't coming quick enough
I'm gonna just clean that [ __ ] up myself
what is the sense of the candles
um something sweet
smelling good something sweet like you
because you're sweetie like me that
makes sense yeah right on Brown
um do you because I you know on this
project you say that you're the the
queen of the bay which I mean yeah
well you know I've never like the queen
of California
you know I went to USC right I mean I
mean I don't want to self-proclaim my my
the queen statement but when I'm in
certain cities or I'm in certain areas
they'll just like call me this and call
me that and I've been called the queen
of California I've been called many
Queen things but I don't think it was
more of a
like it's not something that like I'm
trying to title that's why I had another
voice that say it you know I don't like
when people like self-proclaim sometimes
I mean listen little Wayne called
himself the best rapper alive as he
should though and T.I said he was the
Kayla South as he should though but when
TI said that everybody was like who the
[ __ ] is this guy because it was like I
think it was on the second album he said
that on uh uh
trap music right trap music
um but yeah I think you know it's okay
to just you because who else is going to
do that all right no but I feel like as
they should because they had you know a
catalog but because I'm just heating
back up again you know I appreciate the
titles but I still feel like I got
something to prove right and queen is a
big statement it is a big stick it's a
huge statement yeah that's fair
um break down the uh the uh acronym I
think I got that right for [ __ ] that
was powerful yeah Utopia Supreme sacred
and yummy
the yummy
that's eat it all look don't be wasteful
that's great how like was that is this
something you obviously came up with
this acronym yourself I didn't know if
this was like already out there or
something well I come up with acronyms
for everything that you know that can be
misinterpreted or
you know when you are always saying like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I want people with a
woman to know when I say it it's coming
from an empowering place like a
tournament of endearment maybe it's a
positive thing it's a positive thing
right yeah I think like Tupac did that
with the n-word like he broke down Thug
Life well and and the n-word right yeah
never ignorant I can't even I'm not even
gonna say what it is because it's kind
of like I'm like halfway spelling it out
and I don't want people to put that on
me okay but that being said
um yo how do you feel about like uh
this state of because when I first met
you it was probably 2017 or 18. it was a
long time ago yeah and um
I even think back then like
being a female rapper was like very
yeah I feel like it was it was an uphill
battle because you know we we always
hear people talk about like you know for
so long there was like just Nikki and
then everybody else and I feel like when
we first met like cardi was heating up
but this like movement of like the
biggest rappers in the world are pretty
much all female now and it's like it's
it's the most thriving landscape for
female rappers ever
um how do you feel like obviously being
a part of that growth and that movement
like are you noticing like things change
I'm noticing it yeah
because you know it's what it's four or
five years in this it's crazy that
you're because I still look at you like
a new artist but you're kind of like you
know if I still feel no that's why I
said earlier I feel like I got something
to prove yeah you're like knocking on
you know OG status low-key
stop it I'm saying like there's like a
bunch of new young artists who probably
look up to you now is that weird to like
have people looking up to you and you
kind of came up looking up to other
artists as well
um no because I feel like as an artist
with a big platform you have like a duty
to inspire yeah so like when these girls
like do come to me for advice and they
do like pay me respect I give it right
back to them yeah and you're also um I
just saw um my boy Nico Blitz shout out
to Nico the Filipino Bambino he did this
little Tick Tock mix
and it was like uh with all Filipino
artists and like he put like a fact
about each person and he played one of
your new songs and he was he put
something up about your foundation
um talk about the so I see Foundation I
see baby Foundation I see baby okay I
see baby all right yeah let's get that
right
um but like yeah he was saying something
you guys
do a lot of [ __ ] so like what do y'all
be doing at the foundation well our
first official event is in December okay
it's in Sacramento Vegas in Oakland and
what me and my grandmother is basically
doing she helps me run the program but
we're gonna go into like black and brown
communities and teach about financial
literacy because me being like
I'm like an adult now and I'm still
learning about it but imagine if we
taught the kids at a young age to where
it just became second nature to them
yeah financial literacy it's crazy that
it's not like the number one thing
taught at school because you get out of
high school and you don't know like
about your credit score or how to like
Leverage system system in do you have um
do you have a nice credit score I do was
it what is it no it's like seventh
heaven maybe in the
maybe getting a little higher than that
like high sevens I gotta check it again
if you hit 800 ever at any point in your
life no not yet yeah I think I'm like a
780. I don't know what I have to do to
get at 800 because I know people with
800 I'm like how do you get that like
I don't know yeah I mean you're teaching
financial literacy I'm asking you I know
my grandmother is that's why I said I'm
still learning what up you always
stopping the interview real quick to
tell you about our good friends at my
bookie we're live in my room right now
in Las Vegas and if you're not in Las
Vegas like me and you want to gamble on
Sports and the easiest most convenient
way you want to get that money man
listen NFL season we got college
football we got NBA going stupid right
now all you got to do is sign up right
now at my bookie using the promo code
bootleg and they will match your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars that's
right whatever you deposit up two
thousand dollars they're gonna match
that they're gonna give you free money
to gamble with so what the [ __ ] are you
doing inflation is crazy everybody can
use some extra money they're gonna give
you some free money to play with if you
make your first deposit using that promo
code bootleg up to a thousand dollars
they're gonna match it uh I'm gonna tell
you what this this weekend
Cardinals versus Niners Monday Night
Football Mexico City
I don't like my Cardinals go heavy on
them Niners all right that's all that's
my bet for the week all right let me
know what you gotta hit me on Instagram
and all that don't forget to sign up and
get this money with me at my bookie all
right go to my bookie right now stream
games bet on them you could live bet
them you could do the props and of
course they got the live casino all that
mybookie promo code bootleg sign up
right now and they're gonna match your
money up to a thousand dollars let's get
back to the interview what are some
things that um you would say like basic
financial literacy stuff that you have
picked up from your grandma
I would say one thing that she's taught
me is that the biggest misconception of
having money in black and brown
communities is thinking that you have
money because it's in your savings but
if it's not like compounding if it's not
accruing any interest then the money
isn't really working for you and you
want to get to a point where like you're
dispersing your funds so that you can
have high credit scores your credit can
be better and so that you know your
wealth is working for you while you're
sleeping yeah because if you just have a
regular savings account there's no like
barely any interest
and it's just sitting there so you might
as well put that money to work or like
you said put it in some sort of
investment account where you get like
actual
you know
as guaranteed of returns as you can have
and then also do you do you like use a
credit card for everything and then paid
off at the end of the month
that's what I do I just buy everything
on my credit card but I paid off to zero
at the end of the month do you pay yours
off all to zero every month I gotta ask
my accountant that's fair yeah you're
you got you got account with money me I
got just you know okay I'm trying to get
there though
um yo you kind of have like a a pretty
uh you know I feel like um when we think
of like
Superstar status you're you're a
superstar at this point thank you yeah
um you had a your own meal and [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying McDonald's meal
yeah yeah that was that was one of my
favorite
um brand deals no that's insane not
everyone's getting McDonald's I think it
was like you Travis and like J Balvin
and Mariah Carey yeah and Mariah her
campaign was hella cute yeah
um what was like for you
when you put together the McDonald's
meal
is it like something like really are
eating or are you just like yo this this
kind of some [ __ ] that I like so that's
how I got the deal because I would
always go live like you know when you're
coming home lit from like the club of
course so I would be coming omelette
McDonald's the only thing that's open
and I would just make my concoctions on
live and they would go viral every time
yeah McDonald's to me and I'm not saying
this because they gave you a bag but I
always say this and people give me [ __ ]
I think it's the greatest fast food
restaurant I love it ever and I mean
obviously people will be like in and out
or whatever but I'm like yo McDonald's
is like there's a reason why they're
number one um that [ __ ] is crack uh-huh
yeah do you put fries on your burger
so you didn't see the sweet email I I it
was like a certain type of sauce right
no so I ordered it because my wife is a
she's Miss icy [ __ ] everything so you
get to make chicken you put the fries on
it
if you feel and you know a little risky
add a cheeseburger with it
put some ranch and some sweet and sour
sauce what you put cheeseburger on the
chicken sandwich it's like a Scooby-Doo
sandwich so it's chicken and a burger
patty yeah Jesus and fries and sweet and
sour sauce and Ranch hear it do you
smoke weed
occasionally that sounds like some
pothead ass [ __ ] right there no I just
like to eat hey man listen
shout out to you because if I that kind
of if I eat that [ __ ] all the time be
[ __ ] it I'd be looking crazy out here
but I also like you know white white
people we don't put on weight or age
well so I gotta like be super careful I
just got on keto and lost a bunch of
weight because I was eating too much
McDonald's here I got fat as [ __ ]
um yo let me ask you this sweetie
because I feel like
you for whatever reason and not even
just you but I feel like with this
project and just in general
um I think that like there's a lot of
double standards in music and even
popular culture when it comes to like
when a woman does something and when a
man does something and I feel like
you've dealt with that publicly for like
a while like how do you deal with like
some of the hate some of just the like
people just you know not to get into
specific situations but just people
always speculating about your your
personal life your business online
I mean when it comes to getting you know
Flack or whatever you want to call it
about my art
um I think the biggest thing that keeps
me in a mental in a healthy mental space
is you know one of my mentors Big Bob he
teaches me you know create don't compete
if you're always creating you're not
necessarily looking at what the
competition is doing what the critics
are saying because you're so busy over
here creating so anytime I see myself
going down a rabbit hole of like
negativity I'll just start thinking
about let's let me work on video
treatments let me start mood boarding
let me start writing writing a new song
you know like channeling my energy
somewhere else to keep your kind of like
your mind busy exactly also like you
know that kind of [ __ ] is like usually
not very productive to like like I I
always uh try to stay away from Reading
comments like when we drop interviews I
don't go into the comments so I feel
like it's a double-edged sword though
because I like to interact with my fans
true I was like I have to see some of
the bad to get yeah because if you're
going live you can't like not see what's
right
uh-huh people probably seeing some wild
ass [ __ ] uh they do be saying someone
how many people have you blocked on
Instagram hello people if you had to
give me like a what's the over under is
it like more than a thousand
um you know I'm not sure I've been
blocking people since they started
allowing you to block so yeah I think I
went through my block uh I think I at
least got a thousand people blocked for
sure that's why you got to protect your
piece yeah I'm like yo don't get the
[ __ ] out of it you'll get blocked real
quick coming on my page with some
[ __ ] uh for sure how crazy are
sweeties DMS these days
like do you got like like listen message
requests do you even open them like you
know how you could like you get your DMs
that you see right away and then there's
like just anybody can throw a DM at you
do you ever just go through and see if
like fans hit you up or you know I'm
sure you're getting random depicts just
in and out of that thing you know what I
appreciate now
um Instagram blurs the picture they do
and if you know what
if you're paying close attention yeah
you can see the outline of it so I don't
even open it because it'd be blurred out
it should be like that that looks like a
blurry dick yes so I don't even open it
and what's up with with Instagram
allowing all these porn pages to to tag
and like the tag photos
like if you go to a lot of celebrities
tags it's like a whole bunch of porn I
didn't know they had porn on IG it's
it'd be all up in my text and I'm like
how is Instagram allowing this because
Twitter's Wild
what's your algorithm like oh no it's
better okay I cleaned it up I've cleaned
it up it was it for a while though it
was [ __ ] up okay because like you know
I've had Twitter since 09 I used to
follow a bunch of porn chicks whatever
but it got to the point where like
it was like Russian Roulette if I opened
my laptop in front of my wife or kids
so I can't open my laptop and if I just
go to Twitter like man you just never
know what the [ __ ] gonna pop up the
algorithm so I had to unfollow hello
people it was not even the algorithm it
was just I was following you know a
bunch of sick [ __ ] and um but what's
crazy though is like my friends are
terrible like sick [ __ ] and if they
like something on Twitter it pops up in
my feed damn so Flack likes some sick
[ __ ] on some which I'll be liking no
don't listen to him he we won't talk
about his internet history
hahaha
this man right here he you know he's my
producer he edits all my videos right so
we have a laptop for the bootleg head
podcast and it's signed into my gmail oh
so
I'm on my phone and I look up
Google right and and it has my Google
search history and the last thing I
searched
let's just say with some wild [ __ ] and
I'm like what the [ __ ]
I'm like I know I didn't look that up
and then I was like oh
so I called him and I said hey dude if
you're gonna look up porn make sure it's
not while you're logged into my [ __ ]
Gmail
you know what the worst though is is one
like
you know on your phone how you can swipe
out of things like let's say you forgot
to lock like whatever essay is Twitter
and whatever was last on your Twitter is
still up okay it's like some wild [ __ ]
so you think you're on your phone
everything's like moving how it's
supposed to and then you go to the app
it's like the worst when you're like
around a lot of people oh yeah you know
that happens to me at an award show what
what wait what happened
I have some wild [ __ ] on my phone and I
opened it and I almost like
through my phone in the air because I
was so embarrassed I was like everybody
wait what was on your phone was it
important I can't tell you that was it
like was it like some some smuts some
nasty stuff some risky [ __ ] some risky
[ __ ] some risky [ __ ] some blur dicks it
was more than that Jesus
was it like personal material or like
stuff online I'm just gonna keep coming
to myself what up we gotta stop the
interview real quick we're live in Vegas
right now uh listen fellas if you're
watching this and you need a little
extra pep in your step you know what
step I'm talking about I'm talking about
that dick step damn it all right if you
need some help with that dick of yours
uh Pluto is here to save the day that's
right same exact ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis but here's the catch no
awkward doctor's appointments it comes
straight to your door in a chewable form
very discreet packaging very discreet
billing uh you don't have to go to a
random waiting room while you wait to
get your dick pills from the doctor it's
an embarrassing situation no with
Bluetooth all you do is go to
bluetooth.com right now sign up with the
promo code bootleg that's the most
important part when you sign up with
bootleg at bluetooth.com you get your
first month for free you just gotta pay
five dollars shipping that's right you
go to Bluetooth
you get the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis in that blue True Form
your dick is uh on an all-time high I
mean this thing is [ __ ] booming uh
and then on the other end they just
dropped their new mint chewable which
has the same active ingredients as
Levitra all right which is even stronger
so if you really need some help in the
dick Department
bluetooth's got you all right go get a
free month fellas I don't care if you're
not even dealing with any dick problems
maybe you just want to impress somebody
you're about to [ __ ] Hammer all right
go to Bluetooth get your first month for
free right now delivered right to your
doorstep using that promo code bootleg
go do that and let's get back to the
interview let me ask you this are you
worried about like I'm not saying you
you have stuff like that in your phone
of yourself but
uh you're obviously really famous
so would you ever like freak like do you
ever worry if like dang I don't know if
you've ever sent wild photos to people
in life but like if you have like damn
them shits might leak one day or do you
not give a [ __ ]
you know that's a good question I never
thought about that
I don't know how I feel yeah I mean you
know I always say like uh
go ahead leak them whatever you know
you know one of my homegirls always told
me because this is what she did like she
always makes sure like the photo is Tip
Top so if it ever got out it's just like
oh well yeah it's like it's almost like
a business card
a business card well I'm not I mean I'm
not saying I mean like you know
you know what I mean
okay that sounded terrible I do that
sounded bad he's like what are you
trying to say I don't have a [ __ ]
only fan Jesus by the way
you should do it only fans with
financial literacy advice on it I always
think
[Laughter]
I haven't I didn't subscribe he told me
this but he's like uh he he's you
subscribe and it gives you like YouTube
tips and stuff you know oh wow and
there's like Cooks who have recipes on
there it's not just for the smut you
know I mean DJ Khaled and Fat Joe had a
joint only fans account for a little bit
really yeah I didn't know that yeah they
were just doing like it was like a
like a buddy cop movie but just on only
fans between calendar and Fat Joe so you
know
um who are you a fan of right now that's
just on the come up like help put us on
you know what I'm saying oh I just did a
song with Riki in the Menace hmm I like
her she's from Baltimore she a baddie
shout out to be more anybody out of uh
Northern California you're liking right
now honestly after I drop cause I'm
dropping in some more music but I want
to do like a California search for more
female rappers oh dope we don't really
have like a long line of History we've
had girls that came out but I think it's
time to just show
shed more light on the talent of women
in California that's real because like I
mean obviously you're at the Forefront
of that you know there's like Kamaya
back in the day I love me sometimes fire
hella hard super hard that album was
everything she's amazing yes yes uh who
else uh who else is California Lady of
Rage when I was growing up was dope
I don't know I'm forgetting Day Salon I
like James artist I like herself yeah
she's dope she actually could sing too I
don't know why she'll put the singing
[ __ ] out
um but yeah that that'd be dope maybe
put together like almost like you like a
r project with just like up-and-coming
female I would like to do that that'd be
fire cause I'm producing now I make
beats you're making beats what do you
make beats on
splice splice yeah well you get the
sounds from splice and then I bring it
over where do you bring it over to Pro
Tools or whatever's on the computer I'm
using
I'm still a rookie I just be you know
whatever sounds good I'll just be
dragging it down well that's what's dope
about splices splice is like a
I feel like a nice entry point into
learning how to produce because you can
kind of like
just type in what sound you're looking
for What BPM you want it's like a candy
store of sounds yeah like do you are you
on there a lot just digging around on
splice do you like put the idea together
and then send it to your producer homie
to like refine it or you like totally
like nah I made the beat I got the
bridge built out here you're not there
yet like so my engineer helps me refine
it nice nice he's hella good what is
your um writing process like um are you
like a lot of people nowadays punch in
do you write down stuff do you got the
phone what do you like how are you
writing
um so the last two songs I added to the
single life was memorable in our
reception and what I did is I'll start
the idea in the studio and if like
I feel the energy gets still I'll bounce
it and then I'll go in my car and just
ride around La and just like right wow I
write the best in my car
that's dope so you'll just be in your
car just coming up with ideas yeah I
like driving around Rodeo will you do
like a voice note like
yeah because you can't be like riding
while driving I'll have like this phone
with a beat on and then my other phone
recorded me oh wow that's super dope you
gotta be careful out here though man oh
hell we'll see you driving around L.A
too much by yourself shit's [ __ ] up
out here
it is yeah I mean you obviously went to
college here
um
have you noticed like the turn in like
the city just kind of like things
getting a little crazier out here I mean
I think it's getting publicized a lot
like like there's always been [ __ ]
happening in La obviously but
um it feels like just like
I mean LA and other cities it just goes
to show that this is the reason why
women is running you know
rap and hip-hop because there's just so
much violence and disrespecting the male
music you got to think like remember
when what was that like 16 17 number one
like YG Tyga Chris was out it was like
fun Big Sean it was fun party T Fly yeah
but it was like fun party music it
wasn't like I'm gonna do this to you and
this this you know right so it's like I
feel like we had to raise the vibration
with the music and get back to having a
good time yeah I feel like um
there's definitely a lack of
empathy and love yeah that's real
for real that's real yeah I think some
people are doing it but like you said I
think too that Instagram [ __ ] is like
crazy like I just saw NBA young boy No
Cap going back and forth all [ __ ] day
today on Instagram and I'm just like
Jesus Christ
NBA boys I think it just sound like a
300 million dollar dealer so it's like
you're the [ __ ] off Instagram who cares
with no cap saying like I don't know
that's another humor there
um
pretty [ __ ] music pretty much music is
it done
is is done it's done but this is my
album it's done-ish it's Danish yeah so
like you know it's done but
the right record comes uh comes around
and you can still make the album exactly
features are already turned in no not
yet I like working with artists like in
person like I got to work with Rico
nasty dreezy
um
and a couple more other people I'm like
an in-person type of collaborator I
don't like sending it back and forth
yeah I feel like that's a lost art form
too because nobody's getting in no more
they just send emails yeah crazy super
dope I love her yeah we gotta um a song
called Bay cargo Bay cargo mm-hmm I like
I like that you actually do an album
called Bay cargo [ __ ] it
would do a joint album with somebody I
would do a joint album with dreezy yeah
that'd be fire she's hard I just was
telling my team
Dan when you gonna put this out I want
to tell her before this this comes out I
just saw her last night and it was hella
loud so I was like I got an idea for us
because she asked me about the song but
I've been wanting to like collaborate
with another woman and I really like
dreezy yeah she's dope her and a hip boy
put out a a super fire project uh yeah
and I think that's dope too because I
feel like um I just think it's good to
see
um
like uh artists just working with each
other especially in a female space you
know absolutely pulling each other up
yeah being a fan like I feel like that's
like back to the double standard thing
but remember the fan of a fan with Chris
and tiger oh yeah it was like love
support fine you know gotta get back to
that oh the Tisa Snapback days do you
remember those hats was it that's that
right
I don't know tiger had those [ __ ]
snapbacks booming boy it was that was
such a I remember just watching like
that era in LA and that's what made me
really want to come to LAX I was in San
Diego and I would come to La every
weekend on the um what is it the Amtrak
every weekend so what were we doing in
San Diego San Diego State so you went
okay so you were an Aztec as well and
then I transferred to USC ah you're just
all over California you were the queen
of California thank you do you ever make
it over to Tijuana for good Mexican food
when you live there honestly
I was I would be scared because I would
hear the stories and you know that's the
food over there is crazy I know it's
crazy but I'm like you know that ain't
my hood it's like trying to go down
there
I like my life you know I always like
equate it like if you hear about stuff
like you hear about the worst about a
place on the news it'd be like someone
who's from like
Massachusetts visiting LA and thinking
they're going to get robbed or like
banged on like it might happen that's
Tijuana nah I think
TJ's lit they got great like okay if I
go down there with like you and some
other people that know the area then
yeah but I'm just not going yeah dental
work done there and really the dentist
was fire and uh oysters I get like a
dozen oysters for like eight dollars
you like like seafood your main your
main [ __ ] what's your like favorite food
oh I love me some seafood a seafood boil
some spicy sauce lemon butter do you
cook yeah I cook what's like your if I
if someone were to put you in like a
competition show a seafood pasta that's
your main go-to seafood pasta I don't
eat meat no more but I can make a good
steak
why not what why no meat
um in February I was working a lot and
my body felt like it just kept breaking
down so I was like how do I just remove
something from my diet right um to
improve my health right and I thought
that honestly I didn't think that I was
going to be able to do it but after it
became a habit I kind of just forgot
about meat and then like a month ago I
tried eating um
a huevos Ranchero burrito with some beef
in it and it tastes hella good but when
I tell you my body rejected it in 10
seconds I had to like ran to the
bathroom you had to blow it up
I didn't blow it up it kind of
came back out the other way
so you puked huh you puked I puked I
puked last night yeah it's not fun it's
not in this morning oh it had this
morning yeah I did what color was it uh
this morning was just clear it was like
I was just puking up tequila oh that's
good yeah it was like it was like
something just turned out a water hose
it was [ __ ] up you know what makes a
really safe puke Gatorade
um
so if you know you're going to puke will
you drink the Gatorade drink hella
Gatorade because you're like I might as
well just keep the Gatorade out it keeps
the burn away for some reason nice
you've had some some you got some
experience you gotta work in the morning
[ __ ]
how do you cook your steak you say you
make a good steak what do you do the
cast iron pan like we put it in the oven
how are you making your steak so I like
some I like fruits like marinate okay
you know with the beer the seasoning
whatever in the refrigerator for a
little bit and then I like to bake it
and then once it's done I like to grill
it to like crisp the sides yeah you
gotta sear it there it is oh yeah you're
a real one I learned from my dad shout
out to your pops hey what up y'all
bootleg Kev gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our newest sponsor man
shout out to the homies at hardean Las
Vegas that's right the number one
dispensary in the whole state of Nevada
let alone in the whole [ __ ] country
so many choices of Premium cannabis
ladies and gentlemen it is like how can
I put this you walk into it you go to
Jardin in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sent you
be like yo bootleg Capt sent me they're
gonna take care of you at hardean when I
say selection I mean selection of the
best premium cannabis in the world the
best dispensary there's a reason why
hard Dean is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy and underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview
um
[ __ ] hey let me ask you this because you
grew up in what was bipping crazy in
Sacramento dipping yeah like where in
the when you go to the Bay everybody's
leaving their windows down because every
car is getting bipped they're smashing
the I don't even know what that was oh
my goodness in like the Bay right now
well all the time but I know the band
Sacramento aren't necessarily the same
thing they're not so shout out to
everybody he's like damn
is that when people say yo mazzy's from
the band like no he's not he's from
Sacramento
um but yeah in the in the bay they got
bipping which is crazy it's like uh
in the city if you have a car that looks
like a rental your car your car window
is getting cracked really 100 oh I mean
growing up in the bay
I just remember that like my parents
would always have that
what was that the club the club yeah
yeah the club was also a nice weapon
somebody [ __ ] around to get that club
the problem is they people don't even
want to steal the car no more they just
want to steal whatever you got inside so
now when you go out there everybody just
leaves their windows rolled down are you
serious then yeah if you go to San
Francisco you'll notice just half of the
car's windows are just rolled down
that's hella crazy yeah because I mean
bugs and [ __ ] is getting here they're
like come on in just look and see what I
got because I would rather do that than
have to go and call my insurance company
to get a new window oh my gosh yeah hey
uh talk about best friend because that's
a song that
uh got you nominated for a Grammy
um
big record
was uh was like the the chemistry with
you and Doge are just like off the rip
just
suit was it like an easy record to make
because she seems like super dope like I
mean I've hung out with her she's cool
as [ __ ] we kind of have the same kind of
humor but how was like the creative
process making that record
so I'm at dojo in London so I didn't
even know she was from LA
okay yeah so when I initially met her it
was she was hella cool but I always
thought that she was from London so when
I found out she was in LA like working
with her was a lot more easier right and
when I had the best friend record I just
thought that we'd sound you know good
together and that's someone like I may
not kick it with her but I [ __ ] with her
and I feel like for a record like that
you gotta really have a friendship with
like the person you're making it with
that's not the type of record you just
add somebody on to it you know I mean
it's called best friend yeah you want to
actually be friends with the person you
make this happen absolutely yeah that's
fair who's your actual best friend in
real life though
um the microphone the microphone well
that was a political answer so whoever
no but is it your friend's Circle don't
get offended no when you think of like a
best friend I'm at the studio all the
time but I do got some dope home girls
Fifi Stephanie Khadijah Stephanie put
them on yeah you got two Stephanies damn
I said Stephanie's wife I might say oh I
hope I'm not forgetting nobody you have
an animal like a pet or something I do
want to get a um a pet
yeah
what kind of like a joke just don't get
a Frenchie I'm a more like a pit bull
kind of girl yeah I just feel like like
we get it you got a French Bullet by the
way I got a French Bulldog
you do yes what's the French bulldog's
name his name is Larry Larry yeah okay I
have a dog named Larry and then I have a
Pomeranian named Lebowski The Big
Lebowski my favorite movie
behind you
boom oh wow Have You Ever Seen The Big
Lebowski no I've never seen it with Jeff
Bridges what's it about it's about this
dude
is it in front no no that's just the
French movie poster for it
okay so the Big Lebowski is about a a
loser who lives in L.A
um I'm gonna watch him take a picture of
it yo it's yeah you gotta watch it
and so it starts it pretty much there's
a this guy's name is Jeff Lebowski
there's another Jeff Lebowski in La
that's like a millionaire that owes
these guys a bunch of money so these
guys show up to the poor Jeff lebowski's
house and they beat the [ __ ] out of him
and they piss all over his rug
thinking that he's the guy who owes them
money but then they realize they look
around and they're like wait a minute
isn't this guy supposed to be rich he
lives in this piece of [ __ ] apartment
and so then they just leave
so this guy loved his rug so much that
he rolls the rug up and he he finds the
millionaire Jeff Lebowski and he brings
the rug to his house and he says yo man
they were looking for you they pissed on
my rug I need a new rug and that's just
and then it just is it's just a wild
wild [ __ ] movie oh it sounds like a
it's hilarious like a um like a step
brothers type of move like a super bad
is better than that for sure really yeah
but okay I mean it's the best movie ever
okay number one it's the greatest of all
time what's your favorite movie
oh
no
you don't know no it depends on my mood
well what are your favorite they give me
three movies you really really like that
I really really like yeah I like oh I
love Pan's Labyrinth oh that's a heater
I love that one
um
I like Scarface
okay like that's the type of movie like
I'll just put on like I'm not watching
it but because I watched it so much it
just makes me feel like I'm at home yep
um
and I like zootopia
you know I never seen zootopia that was
like my comfort movie when I was like
running rooms that's a cartoon right
yeah you say when you're renting rooms
what does that mean renting rooms off of
Craigslist
you were renting rooms off Craigslist
yeah
like to live in before I got signed I
didn't know that you didn't know that
yeah oh that's why I would do car wraps
because my crib wasn't nice or whatever
room I was in wasn't nice so you would
be on Craigslist just like room to room
uh-huh damn
was that like a anything sketch ever
happened
yeah so I remember I had found this
place in Northridge
and
um it was a good ass deal it was like
400 for the room too good so it was with
uh a married couple and I remember they
didn't have any kids
they said they didn't have any kids so
when you run a room you go to the
person's house and they interview you
you interview them so she was hella cool
and she kept saying um you can meet my
husband but the husband was was just
never available but I needed a room
right so I was like okay I'm just gonna
move in without meeting the husband but
then as I was moving into the room I
just noticed there was like
like um you know how kids kids put like
like stickers on the wall yeah
it was a whole bunch of like kid stuff
in there and I was like how y'all not
have any kids but this room has been
occupied by a kid before
it it's just the vibe was just really
weird so I was like I feel like if I
move here I'm never gonna leave this
house so I decided not to stay there oh
yeah that's it that's pretty sketch it
was sketch we might have never have
known who you were because they would
have no really for real um hey we gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our partners at Odd Socks our
presenting sponsor here at the
bootlegate podcast listen Christmas time
is approaching faster than you think I
mean we're like [ __ ] a month and a
half away or some [ __ ] whatever uh get
some Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy literally the most
comfortable sock in the world I'm
holding the [ __ ] sock right now you
can save 20 off plus they got boxers now
baby all right go to odd
socksofficial.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at Odd Socks and the podcast at
the same [ __ ] time let's get back to
the interview that's why did you have
you watched Barbarian yet on HBO Max
it's a [ __ ] up movie but it's it's
pretty good you should watch it but
there's like a this guy like keeps like
girls like in under his house and it's
like Kiss the Girls
kind of but like the inbred weird
version It's kind of wild but yeah shout
out to Barbarian
um all right so
I was gonna call it an EP almost [ __ ]
up the project the 60s the sixth piece
is out right now pretty much music
single life
pretty [ __ ] music is on the way it's on
the way
what's your favorite song on the uh
single life
yeah I'm my favorite
um
that's a stupid answer no for real damn
why you gotta be so mean because you
gotta pick one I gotta pick one okay
today what's your favorite what's the
mood
I don't know what is your mood right now
right now what's your favorite right now
what's my favorite
um
they all got different Vibes you butt
dialing somebody yeah oops Jesus
um
I don't know
all of them all of them yeah that's a
typical typical thing to say about your
new music yeah but it's a real answer I
respect it um
yeah well all of them
and uh we're gonna get the album at the
beginning of the year sometime sometime
maybe first quarter
I might show you not sure yet I still
gotta heat up some more
what does that mean it means just you
know
heating my name back up I feel like your
name is I mean you're sweetie
um
it's funny when people say that I don't
know what that means because I still
feel like
I still I don't feel like that whatever
that means hey that's dope that means
that you're still very motivated and you
know you're not content with where you
are that's what be happening a lot of
rappers that get popping and they they
end up like a little pump
yeah damn I mean [ __ ] little punk he put
my number online he did yeah [ __ ] him
why he do that because he's a wiener
what you're getting dick pics
no but do you want me to let me show you
what I got what they wasn't blurred out
though hold on
I gotta show you this this is terrible
so he put my number up because you still
got the same number yeah I mean it was
he put it up for like five minutes
so
I put your number up because we did an
interview and I asked him in an
interview if he thought J Cole predicted
his career properly because you know J
Cole said he was going to fall off and
uh I mean it was a good interview I mean
I guess
but they were like hey like 10 minutes
before the interview was gonna drop they
were like you gotta you guys they they
didn't even ask his manager was like you
can't put that interview out like out of
nowhere and I was like what do you mean
I can't uh-huh you know what I'm saying
like what so the interview came out and
um and then you put my phone up bro but
this is the kind of [ __ ] I was getting
oh random giant pasty white tits in my
text messages like I didn't even know a
little pump had fans like that anymore
that would just like this one's crazy
the devil masonry Illuminati whatever
bro I'll sign pump hit me up this is my
Ig I'm 17 years old
oh they thought you was Lil pump yes oh
no the number he said everybody call me
that's how I look funny yeah I'm sorry
and then like you know you can imagine
the the type of person that would
attempt to call a little pump in 2022
like what kind of people they are you
know what I mean that's exactly who was
hitting me up I was I was driving to San
Diego and my [ __ ] was going crazy oh my
goodness did you have to block some
people
I just uh put my phone in airplane mode
for like an hour oh okay so you didn't
get nothing yeah I was like all right I
know what's happening here this
[ __ ] damn
terrible yeah yeah anyway all right so
look I can't wait to hear the new album
uh the EP well it's not an ep the
six-pack it's out uh anything going on
with the icy I know you got gear you'd
be doing collabs and like what else
March
so you got the merch game is is stupid
it's nice cute little like I'm just
everything will get bigger as I grow but
this is just like a re a reintroduction
so the merch is like like a four piece
yo your nails are long
[Music]
does that make anything difficult in
life like calling somebody or wiping
your ass no I'm used to it it's like an
extension of my body so you have to like
do the wrap though right
hike
when you wipe you have to wrap around
like your hand
you can't just like
with nails like that can you demonstrate
what that looks like okay so if I had
nails like you I would assume that I
would have to take the toilet paper and
I would wrap my hand so then you can
but what happens if you wrap it too
tight
um
I don't know you might have a shitty
hand ew have you ever had a shitty hair
definitely oh oh so have you
at some point in time speak for yourself
everybody in life has had a rough a
rough goal once or twice when you had
that single single plot toilet paper
that you know
in my it might bust through me you know
yeah anyway
sweetie is here appreciate you coming
through
listen to the new music
I'm gonna say just go and press play on
the [ __ ] Song
track three right yeah yeah [ __ ] there
you go and then uh what What's the first
one first one don't say that my goodness
that was a very aggressive record mm-hmm
yeah I like that that was for like my
woman out there yeah
yeah
well don't say nothing
go listen
there it is you got to start getting
these ndas signed you know what I was
thinking that but that's that right ask
how do you just like like look I
appreciate the date to Olive Garden or
wherever someone takes you whatever I do
like Olive Garden of course you do
because Alfredo because you're a real
one listen you told me how you eat your
McDonald's
I totally believe that you like Olive
Garden because Olive Garden's crazy it
is so good with that being said here's a
contract
if this goes any further I'd like to
know that this stays between you and I
okay I'll have you you can send it out
for me and then you could sue them yeah
I could be your lawyer just hire me okay
I don't have a law degree or anything
but I can figure it out you know I think
they'd be scared of you
yeah maybe yeah there it is sweetie
buyer